hi christina nice to see you again how
you doing i am good how about you
good thank you i'm good
i appreciate you talking to me about
this it's um been kind of fun to take
this journey with you guys as i would
imagine it is for you to take this
journey with the character
and it's quite rare to get a continuing
film series that's just about a couple
in their relationship and you know isn't
involving saving the world or beating
vampires or surviving an apocalypse so
what have you most enjoyed about the
opportunity to do these films to play
this character and to just explore their
lives
[Music]
that's such a good question it's well
identified that you know we feel like
this romance is done so often but to do
a franchise in the nature that we have
like you say without those extra added
layers is it doesn't come around to what
we i guess we feel like it does but it
doesn't in its simplicity and i think
part of what makes it so special and
i've enjoyed so much about it is
we're so
i mean it starts with anna's so
brave to
show everything and show the sex scenes
and the arguments and the family aspects
and the darker sides of everything and i
think that
realistic you know darker nature and and
willingness to show every side of it is
is what compels people and what
compelled me and what one of the things
i love most about it
is there anything that's surprised you
about you know telling the story as an
actor were there things that unexpected
things in taking this journey
from an acting standpoint
yeah i mean what's been nice for me is
because i deliberately didn't read the
books because i know so much is going to
change and so much from the books might
not make it to the film just
for me just like the audience kind of
gradually learning like what's happening
as i get each script and
um
i mean there's so many twists and turns
and surprises in this and they are all
like plausible and not like like you say
like
out there far-fetched and unrelatable
like saving the world they're things
like you know family aspects and you
know your dad having crutches that he
needs to deal with and yourself and
mental health issues and trauma past
friendships coming out of college and
they're all relatable things but we're
not we're not glorifying them and
showing them in a perfect fight where
we're you know showing the realistic
nature of sometimes it not being perfect
yeah it's so interesting because when
you look at these movies it's like the
first one was
trouble with their exes and then the
second one was like trouble with their
mothers and now it's trouble with their
fathers and it's not like they're not
trying to survive zombies and it's just
it's interesting how you know you can
really follow these two
through such just normal
issues i feel like
normal normal life when it's not going
great it's
dramatic great entertainment and
sometimes we forget that you know that
there is there's so much entertainment
in the more as you say relatable
seemingly seemingly kind of normal
things you lost me for a bit i'm back
now
um
but yeah yeah uh i do i do love that
that we get a chance to do that and i
think anna's it starts with anna and i
think she kind of set those those things
up so well
it's wild that you shot this third film
in bulgaria the third and fourth film
you shot this you know in in a very
foreign country during a pandemic
what was that like how different was the
experience having to shoot with all of
these new
safety protocols was there ever anything
like it was it just bizarre
yeah i mean
first of all
we're so lucky that we got a chance to
do it we're so lucky that the fans you
know
were so supportive of the franchise that
we even had the opportunity to to go and
do it in the middle of a pandemic and
shoot two back-to-back and yet
climate-wise going from atlanta
summertime to shooting in bulgaria
winter was definitely a jump i mean we
had to like
drink freezing cold water before certain
takes outside so that our breath wasn't
as visible because it was so cold
and yeah scenes coming out of a hot tub
at zero degrees but trying to be slick
and sexy and act like you're not
shivering
um
is yeah it comes with this comes of its
challenges but um the bulgarian crew was
so hard working and and lovely and you
know the new cast members who stepped in
did great great things with their roles
and uh yeah it was
it was surprise it was definitely
difficult it was definitely you know
hard work but um i'm so happy with the
final product and that's kind of all
that matters when you look back as well
sounds like there would also be a very
entertaining blooper reel involved with
this movie then you know what there
would be there would be if the cameras
like came like you know offset and
between between i feel like onset
because of the nature of the film was a
bit more dramatic so we didn't have that
actual bloopers but yeah we did have a
we did have a lot of fun like you know
in the hotel on the 24th floor we all
did we were just like crazy kids locked
up for like three months and obviously
you can imagine us doing
yeah yeah a lot of a lot of fun stupid
stuff
you've got different directors for each
of the first three films what was that
like to have the different visions and
perspectives on these characters while
you guys are sort of the constant
throughout i have to say
the reason it worked was because every
director was so respectful of our
approach and therefore that linear
consistency in how we play the
characters was never you know no one
ever tried to get us to budge on that
front but the style of the films change
and i think that that is rel is quite
welcomed in a in a series of books where
there are seven books i love the fact
that we've had different directors who
have allowed to put their own stamp on
it and therefore there's going to be
different fans who say i love the sakura
and then it's so much better than the
first or the third and fourth or i love
the three and four but not so much as or
i love the first one and i feel like
it's almost that nice to to think that
that each and every fan gets a little
pocket of something whether they
preferred shane or chances landon or
whether they prefer cause still you know
whoever it may be everyone gets their
own kind of
you know um
their own their own opinion and there's
there's a variety of themes and stuff to
choose from
was it ever weird to act opposite a
different actor playing the same
character in some of these
movies was it ever kind of strange to
have those changes going on well i can
imagine
it being off-putting for the audience to
adapt to it because i've watched things
where people get recast and it's taken
me a minute to adapt to like who you
know who the new person is
but since you're asking specifically how
it is for me joe answered this question
in a really smart way that i completely
agree with which is you do a lot of
scenes where
the camera has to be where the person is
and therefore the person can't be there
and they'll be reading the lines off
screen or they might not be able to be
around they might be having to do
something else so you have the director
or an ad or someone reading the lines
and you're staring at the corner of the
camera and already you're so detached
from reacting with the other actor that
when another actor comes in to replace
them you're like well at least it's a
human being with a face and eyes and
stuff so you can still kind of apply the
same dynamic in the relationship despite
the role being changed but i completely
acceptable for the audience it's
probably a bit more difficult
what was it like to finish the last
scene on the last day knowing that you'd
be saying goodbye to these characters
have you officially said goodbye to him
yet or does it not feel like you're
there yet since the fourth movie still
won't be out for a bit
yeah yeah i mean who knows we might need
to do a random pickup or reshoot and
stuff so i definitely haven't said
goodbye goodbye to him it's not you know
i don't think it's i don't think it's
far from done yet but it was that
bittersweet and it does feel like you
know it does feel like something we've
got we've got somewhere
um
and yeah i think just bittersweet i felt
so proud and accomplished and proud of
everyone and we just you know three
months with all the same people
is like it's it's happy it's a happy
positive feeling of having completed
what you meant to do and you know got to
the end final destination but of course
it's sad to
to have to finish and go home so
bittersweet is a good word to describe
it
how did your first day on the first film
compare it to your last day on the last
film do you feel like a very different
person and actor since you started this
whole process 100 i feel like you would
naturally grow in the ages that i've you
know the age i started to now although
it's only two to three years it
i feel like i've changed massively i
feel like i've had so many incredible
life experiences as well not just
filming the movie but promoting it and
going traveling around talking to fans
and talk to people like yourself and and
um i feel like i have learned so much i
can't almost i almost can't even
highlight one thing but
definitely very different to how i felt
on the first day to wrap it on the last
thing yeah
do you feel like you and josephine have
been on the same page when it comes to
your characters and their relationships
and
their feelings and reactions and when
you guys think they're justified or when
they're not do you tend to feel like
you come at it from the same place or do
you ever have disagreements about how
they're behaving
yeah i feel like
no that's a great question and and like
generally i feel like we are very much
in the same boat and have the same
thoughts and when we don't i feel like
it's only ever beneficial because it
will be like why would i act like that
and be like well because i would act
like this and surely you'd and we'll
bounce off each other to a point where
my character is my character and her
characters her character so she can do
whatever you know i mean we're not the
direct we don't have any say on what
other each other is going to do but i
feel like because we've been with each
other for you know on the journey with
each other's characters we're almost
like the best people to ask advice on so
as much as we won't tell each other what
to do whenever we do disagree it's
really useful to have someone else's
opinion who's been there from the start
and you know has a good sense of what's
right and wrong for your character
what is your favorite moment between the
two of them in in this third film
because we shot three and four back to
back i've confused some scenes because
it was all shot out of order as well
with three and four
um
but i think there's one i think the
argument where um
i think it's where she says uh you i
want you know uh i'll be there i'm
talking about seattle i'll be there and
he says well that's not enough
is that i think that happens in the
kitchen
and and they've just like woken up it
might be a different thing not confusing
with but there's one in the kitchen
where it just feels like a very very
like natural argument that isn't over
the top and isn't like shouting at each
other and isn't going to end in plates
crashing and people walking out but just
a very kind of more tame
i don't know um i think i'm confusing a
different scene but one of the more dem
you know
i guess like relatable arguments that
isn't at 100 was nice to see because
it's not it's not like it's perfect or
it's a crazy argument sometimes you do
have bits in the middle and it's nice to
show them sometimes
harden gets some shocking news at the
end of this film so he's not really left
in the best place
what would you say to tease the fourth
film for fans for for fans that like you
know are sitting and screaming at their
screens when they're watching the end of
this movie what would you say to like
hold them over give them hope for the
fourth movie
you know what i i feel like
i feel like
i almost feel like this is cheeky to
save i almost feel like a cliffhanger
alone does it i'd almost want to like if
they were like oh what and came to me
for an answer i'd want to just be like
you know i feel like i feel like saying
nothing is enough to is enough to get
them back after that cliffhanger so i
almost wouldn't want to tease but you
know come on you've got to want to fight
you could you have to want to find out
after after that so yeah um
[Music]
just just stick with him if harding can
keep trying to be a better person
and you know and he's still sticking at
it then then you guys can stick out for
one more film and see if he makes it
there
how fun is it then to get to have those
kind of cliffhangers because that's also
something you don't get in movies very
often because you never know if you're
gonna get to finish telling the story so
people tend to not want to just leave it
in such a moment like that is it fun to
get to be able to play with the audience
in that way knowing that they will get
to come back
i'm really i'm realizing it's quite like
sadistic how much i enjoy like watching
the fans go through that like no what's
going to happen or when they're watching
the trailer and they can't wait to watch
it like that excitement is just like
yeah you can't put a price on on on that
kind of especially like watching that
that is is kind of what i yeah what i do
it for so i i love that
the cliffhangers have become like a kind
of iconic notorious aspect of the after
franchise uh yeah i love it
how do you
pick the next project after this because
it seems like when you finish something
like this
where you go next is important because
people are going to see you as this
character so what are you looking for as
far as you know finding something
completely different
yeah i mean that's exactly it i would
love to i would love to just explore all
the other
you know styles and types of roles and
genres of films
i definitely want to do some like darker
crime stuff uh some some thrillers some
you know
uh cat and mouse twists and turns
yeah uh a psychological thriller um or
like a script with a lot of
people on the edge of your seat is the
kind of the kind of stuff i'm gonna be
going for but i would love to just keep
an open mind and continue to do like a
variety of stuff i want to keep testing
myself and try and do a little bit of
everything
are you a comedy person do you feel this
comedy scare you do you feel like you
would take
the right comedy there are some comedic
elements in the film i did called the
loneliest boy in the world that that i
know i can't talk about too much because
i still haven't seen like a press
release but i can't wait till i can
start talking about it that has some
comedic moments in so yeah
um no that doesn't scare me in the right
in the right the right project i'd love
to
well i appreciate you talking about this
it has been so fun to watch this journey
and to talk to you about it i appreciate
it
christine always a pleasure lovely to
see you again and thank you